while he may not have been as productive
and I think we all have to agree he
wasn't as productive right as he was in
his early life he became this iconic
figure I loved show the picture of the
sandals i love this picture there we go
yeah yeah okay who can't love this guy
those are actually now we know excellent
research that he is actually wearing
sandals that are a woman size 11 as
confirmed by the man who sold them to
him David Rothman in suffolk county long
island we had to get that in but this is
actually a great kind of a tradition
among physicists that would you look
like on the weekend yeah nice nice nice
yeah good didn't take that down now
thank you oh there's so much for your
shoes young lady right over there yeah
hi Tracy um there is so much folklore
around Einstein I mean I love the
clipping from the New York Times where
he says he's incapable of doing his
taxes because they're so complicated I
mean and lit up any cultivates that too
i mean you study this more than I but
he's well aware oh yeah yeah there you
go he's well aware what an issue yeah
and I think he enjoyed starting to
starting the myth going forward yeah so
he he he kind of enjoys being a
celebrity right I mean he's no Kim
Kardashian but he's enjoying being a
celebrity well he didn't get signing
tours but you know there's lots of kids
in prison probably still alive who he
helped with her math problems he was
this kind of avuncular as you say genial
person I mean I guess he did you know
that's obviously Charlie Chaplin and he
wouldn't take occasional star turn but
you know he never really left princeton
from 33 for a prolonged period of time
now that's the premiere of city lights
and there's this famous a probably
apocryphal story where you know Einstein
and chaplain coming on the red carpet
and there's this crowd cheering and
Einstein says to
chaplain allegedly what does it all mean
and chaplain says nothing yeah which
again is you know that that story itself
as part of the cultivation of the myth
the other worldly man um yeah he did
like being a celebrity but he also used
it I mean he actually made practical use
of it one time when he came to America
he made reporters who wanted to
interview him make a small donation to
to help with one of his causes i think
it was displaced refugees he obviously
used his celebrity to do all kinds of
attempts of political activism including
writing to roosevelt that it was time
for the u.s. to start paying attention
to the atomic bomb so I mean he would he
he was willing to be famous if it helped
him advance causes that he believed in